hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast testing for crusty
specific antigen PSA to screen or not to
screen
presented by sharam Shahen jian PhD
senior health scientist laboratory
research and evaluation branch division
of laboratory systems center for
surveillance epidemiology and laboratory
services office of public health
scientific services Centers for Disease
Control and Prevention I am Christina
Mahalo collaborates and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this education
web seminar presented by elaborates
labyrinth is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green a keep the green Q&A button
located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also please notice
that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know you're having a
problem this educational presentation
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the button in the bottom
left corner and follow the process to
obtain your credits please join me in
welcoming dr. Shama and Gianna I will
now turn the presentation over to him
the floor is all yours
now
my presentation would focus on issues
relating to the effectiveness of cancer
screening and prostate cancer screening
and I would begin by providing the
criteria for effectiveness of any health
screening that has been adopted by the
World Health Organization I will follow
this presentation by presenting the
major biases that impact a perception of
a screening effectiveness and most of
these biases are favorable in terms of
adopting screening then I will continue
with providing the recommendations by
major US Health Organization's
on the use of PSA tests to screen for
prostate cancer and then examine PSA
screening to stray from for prostate
cancer in terms of how this test meets
each of the whu-oh effectiveness
criteria and finally conclude with
several key messages that relates to
consequences of cancer screening in
general and prostate cancer screening in
specifically using the PSA test the
learning objectives of my presentation
here are to audience to be able to
describe the wh ostrich area for
effectiveness training and use PSA as a
testing model to evaluate how this
particular test needs each of those
screening criteria also describe
major screening biases the major groups
that are targeted by cancer screening
and any screening for that matter and
the consequences of cancer screening and
PSA screening and finally describe the
current perspectives on the
recommendations and guidelines relating
to PSA screening for prostate cancer the
w-h-o striking earth criteria that were
first proposed by younger and Wilson in
back in 1968 that remains to be still at
adopted by the wh all can be in a framed
into seven broad categories the first
category has to do with the disease
having significant societal burden of
disease in terms of health burden and
socio-economic burden the second
criterion has to do with the clinical
performance of the test used in
screening negative and positive
predictive values how predictive and
negative result is to indicate absence
of disease and how predictive a positive
test result is to indicate disease the
target population should find the
screening test to be acceptable to them
and the screening program should be
feasible this is the third criteria and
the fourth criteria has to do with
acceptable cost-effectiveness and that
has to do with life years saved or
quality adjusted life years saved and
and usually the cutoff line is $100,000
for life year saved and increasing the
quality
just in life years saved is used as a
measure in terms of cost utility
analysis the the screening program
should effectively intervene before
onset of disease there should be a good
asymptomatic phase so that the disease
could be intervened stopped or the
progression of the disease could be
slowed down
certainly in cases of screening that
there is not an net and significant net
benefit to the patient there should be
informed consent on the part of the
patient and certainly patient
confidentiality if warranted should be
adopted and finally where the rubber
meets the road there should be a better
population health outcome with screening
when compared with access of screening
I've listed here and on this slide
the major screening biases lead-time
bias has to do with finding the disease
earlier but not necessarily impacting
the outcome here the window would be
shifted to the left without necessarily
impacting the time of death the length
bias has to do with the fact that the
screening tends to detect more slowly
progressing diseases so in the screening
trials when the screening is compared
with no screening individuals who have
submitted to a screening seem to have a
better health outcome and that is
because of the length bias because the
screening tends to detect
slowly progressing cancers and miss
aggressive cancers then there is an
issue of presenting the risks to the
patient in terms of relative visa vie
absolute risk presented to the patient
for example that the risk of the disease
dying from cancer is decreased by say
twenty to thirty percent looks quite
impressive versus the same information
given in absolute risk of where reducing
the chance from dying from cancer by in
one in 1,000 in a ten to fifteen year
time period the first presentation seem
to favor screening why the second
presentation of absolute risk which is
more objective does not make a screening
so attractive and then this and this is
very important diseases specific in the
case of cancer cancer specific mortality
is used as the primary outcome measure
versus all cause mortality and that's
extremely important because many cancers
individuals die from diseases other than
cancers that results from interventions
from diagnostic maneuvers treatment
modalities that are not captured in
cancer specific mortality and the gold
standard of any screening trial is all
cause mortality but the issue with all
cause mortality is that we need more
than 1 million patients in randomized
controlled clinical trials in order to
show a significant change and that is
why virtually all screening trials use
cancer specific mortality as the primary
outcome measure
this is life shows that the
recommendations by the major health
organizations that can be grouped into
two broad categories the first group led
by the US Preventive Services Task Force
and also College of preventive medicine
Academy of Family Physicians they
advocate not using PSA screening of men
at any age currently the US Preventive
Services Task Force is revising or
updating the recommendations they
released a draft in April of this year
and perhaps later in the year
the final recommendation would come up
but the current recommendation currently
on the part of the US Preventive
Services Task Force a recommendation
that the CDC follows is not to recommend
screening of men at any age and the
other set of recommendations are
targeted for only a certain age group of
men and that is to offer as screening to
men beginning at the age 50 to 55 up to
69 but only when there is an informed
shared decision-making and only when the
men agree to be screened and not screen
men with expected life expectancy of
less than 10 years and this
recommendation is currently by the
American Cancer Society urological
Association college of medicine and the
rationale for this is that the second
recommendation is that there is some
strong likelihood of reducing cancer
specific mortality and because of
screening and so they should have the
option to be screened or not to be
screened the previous group recommend
against the screening because there's a
likelihood that the net benefit of
screening is negative namely considering
the complications that can result from
screening and subsequent treatment the
quality adjusted life years seem to be
less with the screening compared to no
screening now this next set of slides I
would like to discuss the PSA screening
for prostate cancer against each of the
seven whu-oh criteria the first criteria
if you recall was having significant
societal burden of suffering in terms of
health and social economic variables
according to the NCI the latest estimate
for this year there would be about 160
1000 a new diagnosis of prostate cancer
made during the year however about
27,000 men will die from their prostate
cancer as opposed to other causes the
prostate cancer for men constitutes 11%
of all diagnosed cancers which is
significant but it leads to only 4% of
all cancer deaths so certainly the
societal burden of the disease is a
large but we should note that less than
one in six men diagnosed with prostate
cancer actually died from their cancer
rather than from other causes five out
of six died eventually from other causes
and not from their cancer
the second criterion has to do with
clinical performance of the PSA test and
I've listed here on this slide the
positive predictive value negative
predictive value as well as a clinical
sensitivity and specificity and the
positive predictive value of this test
when it was started to be used back in
the early 1990s as a screening test the
studies showed that the majority of men
that have positive findings named the
PSA of more than or equal to 4.0
microgram per liter one out of four of
them only had prostate cancer evaluated
by a biopsy and the remaining men that
had positive PSA values exceeding this
level were due to non malignant
conditions mostly benign prostatic
hyperplasia and also due to inflammation
and infection of the prostate gland in a
study that was conducted over a
seven-year period subjecting a group of
men to regular PSA screening as well as
digital rectal examination and and none
of them showed any evidence of disease
when all of these men were subjected to
prostate biopsy about 15% of them showed
a positive were positive for cancer this
shows that the negative predictive value
of this test is 85% namely out of the
people that are supposed are negative in
their screening 15% actually do have
cancer in an elegant study that the
Thompson and colleagues did in
back in 2004 and was published in JAMA
listed here when a group of men all of
them were biopsied under PSA measure PSA
serum PSA was measured only 20% of them
that were positive in biopsy at PSA
value exceeding 4.0 microgram per liter
so this shows that there is a great
number of individuals that have the
disease and PSA test actually does not
detect them and when we use the
relationship between clinical
specificity and positive predictive
value prevalence of 1.8% for all
adjusted all races and clinical
sensitivity has noted at the bottom of
the slide we get a figure of 75% for
clinical specificity meaning that
individuals that don't have disease a
quarter of them actually come up with
positive PSA findings so based on this
slide alone and the clinical performance
of the PSA death test to diagnose
prostate cancer is not that impressive
is there PSA screening for prostate
cancer acceptable and feasible to
implement based on evidence of common
use being PSA being the most widely not
based screening test in men and given
the fact that about 30% of men between
the ages of 50 and 64 annually get
screened and 10 to 15% of men above 65
get about about 65 and older get
screened based on the studies that are
noted here it appears that the test is
to the US population and certainly it is
feasible to implement in terms of
cost-effectiveness however really the
findings are mixed a most authoritative
study that was conducted that look at
various screening strategies sound
testing once every four years of the
group of men between fifty sixty nine to
be cost effective at about ninety two
thousand dollars per life year saved
when you use the cutoff value of one
hundred thousand per life year same as
the criteria below which to be cost
effective and in many other scenarios it
exceeded this threshold and all of the
studies that have been conducted under
wide range of assumptions for quality
for utility to determine quality
adjusted life years so actually a
decrease in quality adjusted life years
well the PSA test is not very good in
predicting aggressiveness in the sense
that a little over half of all cancers
are over diagnosed and also over treated
and any approach that would find more
castles without quality quantifying the
clinical significance by virtue of not
having a good prognostic markers tend to
increase overdiagnosis and overtreatment
which is a harm to this man being
straight is informed consent comedy
practiced in one study about half of
they surveyed he did not routinely
discuss PSA screening with men while
ordering the test in a CDC study of 2013
behavior risk factor surveillance
systems meant from three states Delaware
Hawaii and another state that I don't
recall now I need to go to my notes they
were found not to be engaged in
screening the majority the vast majority
of them 64% of them did not engage in
any shared decision-making so the
evidence does not support effectiveness
or infomercial decision making to
improve appropriate use of PSA screening
for cancer in the sense that discussions
of disadvantages or advantages and
disadvantages attended even to increase
uptake of screening and discussions of
uncertainties surrounding screening did
not impact PSA utilization rate so it
appears that provision of the
information is not impacting the
screening rate at at times increases it
so but given that all health care
organizations including the CDC advocate
inform the shared decision-making there
is numerous barriers that have been
reported in the literature to dissuade
informed decision making that relates to
discomfort discussing life expectancy
not of time of the busy clinicians
discomfort with showing this discussing
the uncertainty for effectiveness
PSA screening there is limited awareness
of PSA screening guidelines by many
physicians and certainly patients
expectations come into play to have
increased PSA screening when it is not
warranted and certainly fear of
malpractice dedications that has been
documented in the literature as being
advocating screening even though
evidence-based guidelines do not support
string of say older men certain age
population for for sure the impact of
decision support systems on the
provision of them to the patient has a
mixed result some studies have shown no
impact on PSA screening why some studies
showed that provisional in decision
support tools to the patient may
actually decrease utilization rate and
this is both on the part of the clinic
clinician clinical decision support
system as well as support interventions
provided to the patient so the on both
ways there's mixed findings but the
clinical decision support system if it
is a specific study has documented that
screening of older men 75 year and above
may be decreased and the decrease may
will be sustained over time but the
issue with the support interventions for
men is less clear in the sense that some
of these interventions seem to have the
opposite impact to increase screening
rate and finally better population
health outcome which is the
last criterion that is used by major
health organizations in terms of
evaluating screening effectiveness based
on a meta-analysis of five randomized
control trials including the European
and US trials there was no reduction in
cancer specific mortality rate that not
just higher conducted in Europe in eight
countries however showed a significant
reduction in cancer specific mortality
rate in the screening on compared to
control arm and both the u.s. trials and
European trials have been criticized
with the u.s. trial having a high
contamination rate in the control arm
there is a screening PSA screening once
every two and a half years ideally you
don't want to have any screening in the
control arm but unfortunately because of
the popularity of PSA screening it is
still in the control trials it is being
adopted the European Shriner has been
criticized because of non-uniform
implementation and differences in the
screenings size and different study
protocols that were implemented but
having said all these none of these
screening trials alone or in combination
showed any statistically significant
impact on the old important all cause
mortality which is really the gold
standard of any screening test there are
certainly many adverse impacts of PSA
screening and we know that most men with
PSA screening 70 to 80 percent of them
undergo invasive treatments surgery
surgery or radiation therapy and these
treatments are not far
less up to five in one thousand men die
within one month of prostatectomy
removal of prostate glands and 1% was 7%
would have serious complications but
they would survive prostatectomy and
radiation therapy gives right to myriad
of conditions erectile dysfunction
urinary incontinence and bowel
dysfunction in at least a quarter of man
and these are major complications that
certainly impact quality of life so
really five major groups of individuals
that are targeted by cancer screening
patients with no cancer where morbidity
and mortality actually may become
significant
if the diagnostic maneuvers and that
would go into pursuing the rule in or
rule out would cause two significant
morbidities patients with the only
adverse events resulting from diagnosis
and treatment that would not be
consequential if they had not screened
and certainly in this group of patients
the second group there would be a
reduction in quality adjusted life years
patients successfully treated regardless
of his screening so in in this group of
patients we don't see any impact of his
screening because when the person came
up with the clinical signs and symptoms
the disease was treatable and the
screening would not have made any
difference patients with incurable
cancer at time of a screening and these
are a significant minority of cancers
are so rapidly progressing that at one
stage at one year you can have no
disease at the other the subsequent year
you can have disease that has had
already spread and it's already too late
certainly screening does not help these
men or these persons for that matter in
the broader context of cancer screening
but there may be some impact on the
individuals and his his or her family's
decision-making once they find that
there is an aggressive tumor for
decision making at the end of life and
finally and this is the group that
really a cancer screening is designed to
help or individuals who are in sure
having curable disease at the time they
are diagnosed but they are curable if
they are identified by screening and we
really with many cancers and many
diseases but you know we don't know how
large this group of patients are in the
case of transyl screening and laboratory
screening for cancer the two disease
conditions that show that the cancer has
a strong net benefit is a cervical
cancer and colorectal cancer but that is
only for certain age groups and all the
other cancers are not supported by
evidence so the major consequences of
cancer screening has to do with
prevention of morbidity and mortality
from the disease itself but at many
times morbidity and mortality are not
significantly impacted that can
certainly be testing Cascades on our
certainties about the disease presence
that can resolve this significant
morbidity and some mortality downstream
there are certainly many cases and this
comes to mind particularly with respect
to prostate and breast cancer diagnosed
of a cancer in situ that is proved to be
inconsequential and could have very well
been left alone but the treatment that
goes into addressing that may have a
significant consequences particularly in
the case of prostate cancer between
these two cancers and certainly as I
noted with the respect to prostate
cancer diagnostic evaluation and
treatment resolved into myriad of
complications an infection of the
prostate bland erectile dysfunction
bowel dysfunction and urinary
incontinence and others so on one hand
better ways are needed to extreme by
using effective broad prognostic markers
to reduce over treatment for prostate
cancer and regretfully we don't still
have very good prognostic markers to
decide which cancers to treat and which
ones to leave alone but on the other
hand if we don't treat men with that
they have consequential cancers that may
result in lack of treatment where the
cancer could be prevented so there's
this calls for screening certain cancers
and acting accordingly to to treat them
in the later years that have been
increasing active surveillance in the
sense that individuals that come
positive they would be monitored more
frequently with PSA tests and digital
rectal exam and you know and the many
men decide to be monitored for some time
but the fact of the matter is most men
finally succumb to wanting to have the
peace of mind having the project glands
removed
with this consequent morbidities as I
mentioned before so ultimately the
question may really become not
necessarily whether to history and
certain men for prostate cancer rather
how best we screen if the men want to be
screened how to best the screen and only
treatment for their cancers when it is
necessary to do so we little bit more a
very well-known urologic oncologist as a
sloan-kettering Memorial Institute in
the 1990s when he like by the way he
died from his prostate cancer he framed
a true very important question if cure
is possible is it necessary
and when cure is necessary is it
possible do we need to treat all cancers
and other effective means to treat them
and do we have effective and validated
prognostic markers to only treat cancers
that are likely to be consequential if
left alone can we identify a man with
aggressive localized cancers early
enough to intervene effectively and if
not can metastatic disease be
effectively treated we can but only
sometimes identify men with aggressive
localized trance or early enough to
intervene effectively and most
metastatic cancers have poor survival
rates despite treatment and we still
lack effective and validated prognostic
markers in order to treat only cancers
that are likely to be consequential if
left alone
criminal nature we must adhere to the
Hippocratic oath ingrained in allopathic
medicine and to first do no harm
please contact me if you have any
further questions the comments that I
have made I should say or those of mine
and do not necessarily reflect the
official position of the Centers for
Disease Control and Prevention thank you
thank you dr. Sheehan Gian for that
informative presentation we will now
start with the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window type
your question into the box that appears
on the screen and click on the send
button well answer as many questions as
we have time for let's get started with
our first question of the day I mean hop
in here okay our first question of the
day asks how is the screening criteria
adopted by the World Health Organization
different from those used for
development of screening recommendations
and guidelines in the United States well
can you hear me then basically the major
difference is that the WH ol has a
criterion that relates to cost
effectiveness or cost utility that is
increasingly being used there are a
number of other criteria that really
goes into the very last criteria that
years with better population health
outcome but the major u.s. Health
Organization's of those some examine
cost-effectiveness their recommendations
is not based on cost effectiveness and
cost utility rather it is based on
clinical effectiveness
excellent thank you for your answer
our next question asks how do the
recommendations by various Health
Organization's for PSA screening for
prostate cancer differ or agree with
each other and what should men do peer
organizations agree old health
organizations agree that prostate cancer
screening should not be done routinely
using the PSA test for men younger than
50 and older than 69 where the
difference comes is with one group led
by the US Preventive Services Task Force
which currently recommends that the
screening should not be done routinely
for any men regardless of age however
the other group led by the American
Cancer Society and urological
Association maintains that there should
be an opportunity giving to men between
the ages of 50 and 69 whether they want
to undergo screening but only after
providing them with an opportunity for
informed and shared decision-making and
this group does not recommend screening
any men with life expectancy that is
less than 10 years
thank you the next question asks what
are some risk factors for prostate
cancer and is there convincing evidence
for effectiveness of prostate cancer
screening and men at high risk such as
African Americans and those with family
history of prostate cancer
well actually the most important risk
factor for having prostate cancer is age
but I should say that there is currently
no convincing evidence that age race or
family history is relevant in terms of
effectiveness of PS PSA screening for
prostate cancer older individuals do
have a greater probability of prostate
cancer but there is a greater
probability of them dying from other
comorbidities and complications and
prostate cancer being typically slowly
progressing would not be a material
issue in that respect in the case of
African American men that has a higher
prevalence of prostate cancer there is
also no evidence that increasing at an
earlier age or the screening more
frequently would result in better Plus
outcome the evidence is not there the
individuals that have a positive family
history a lot of them end up being
diagnosed with more prostate cancer
because they undergo more screening and
as a result they are increasingly
diagnosed and labeled with prostate
cancer but again there is no evidence
that the increase is screening or
earlier screening of this subgroup of
individuals with result in better thank
you and based on time constraints looks
like this will be the last question of
the day and this asks why should that
preferred outcome measure of cancer
screening be all cause mortality in
quality adjusted life years instead of
respectively cancer specific mortality
and life years as I noted previously the
gold standard of any screening trial is
all cause mortality because it can
capture death from causes say resulting
from diagnostic maneuvers and treatment
modalities that could be related to the
treatment of cancer so when a cancer
specific mortality rate is evaluated
that could be a decrease in cancer
specific mortality why in point of fact
there may be an increase in all cause
mortality because many of those
treatments may result into mortality
that is not captured by evaluating
cancer specific mortality the very fact
that the all the screening trials use
cancer
specific mortality results from the fact
that in order to see differences in all
cause mortality you need very large
number of participants exceeding a
million in order to show statistical
difference and that is why the vast
majority of these trials even though
they assess all cause mortality do not
show any significant change in all cause
mortality but it remains to be the gold
standard because of the fact as I noted
earlier that there are mortalities
resulting from the treatment of the
disease itself that is not captured by
cancer specific mortality rates I would
like to once again thank dr. Schaack and
Gian for this presentation I would also
like to thank Records for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through February of
2018 you will receive an email for a
labyrinth letting you know when the
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us and we hope to see you
again here soon at laberd's good bye